hello my name is Herman and I've always
been struck by how how the most
important impactful tsunami-like changes
to our culture in our society always
come from those things that we least
think are gonna have that impact I mean
as a computer scientist I remember when
Facebook was just image sharing in dorm
rooms and depending upon who you ask
sits now involved in toppling elections
I remember when cryptocurrency or
automated trading were sort of ideas by
a few renegades in the financial
institutions in the world for automated
trading or online for cryptocurrency and
they're now coming to quickly shape the
way that we operate and I think each of
you can recall that moment where one of
these ideas felt like some ignore about
the rice of thing and suddenly oh crap
the price of Bitcoin is what it is or oh
crap guess who's been elected the
reality is that you know from my
perspective I think that we're about to
encounter that again and I think one of
the biggest most impactful changes to
the way we live our lives to the ways
were educated probably even to how we
end up making an income is about to come
not from AI not from space travel or
biotech these are all very important
future inventions but in the next five
years I think it's gonna come from video
games so that's a bold claim okay I see
some skeptical faces in the audience but
if we take a moment to try to look at
what video games are already becoming in
our lives today and what just a little
bit of technological advancement is
about to create it starts to become more
of an inevitability and I think the
possibilities are quite electrifying so
let's just take a moment to think about
scale I mean there's already 2.6 billion
people who play games and the reality is
that's a billion more than five years
ago a billion more people in that time
no religion no median nothing has spread
like that and there's likely to be a
billion more when Africa and India
gained the infrastructure to sort of
fully realize the possibilities of
gaming but what I find really special is
and this often shocks a lot of people is
that the average age of a gamer like
have a gasps think about it it's not
sex it's not 18 it's not 1234 it's older
than me and that does are something that
this is an entertainment for children
anymore this is already a medium like
literature or anything else that's
becoming a fundamental part of our lives
you know once that I like is that people
who generally picked up gaming in the
last sort of 15 20 years generally don't
stop something changed in the way this
medium is organized and more than that
it's not just play anymore right and
you've heard four examples today but
people are earning an income playing
games and not only obvious ways yes
that's a sport there's prizes there's
the opportunity to make money in a
competitive way but there's also people
earning incomes modern games building
content in them doing art in them I mean
there's something at scale akin to the
Florentine Renaissance happening on your
kids iPhone in your living room and it's
being ignored now what's even more
exciting for me is what's about to
happen and when you think about gaming
you're probably already imagining that
it features these massive infinite
worlds but the truth is games have been
deeply limited for a very long time in a
way that kind of we in the industry have
tried very hard to sort of cover up with
as much trickery as possible like the
the metaphor I like to use if you let me
dig out for a moment is the notion of a
theater you know for the last 10 years
games have massively advanced the visual
effects the physical immersion the front
end of games but behind the scenes the
actual experiential reality of a game
world has remained woefully limited I
sort of put that in perspective for a
moment like I could leave this theater
right now I could do some graffiti get
in a fight fall in love I might actually
do all of those things after this but
the point is that all of that would have
consequence it would ripple through
reality all of you could interact with
that at the same time it would be
persistent and those are very important
qualities to what makes the real world
well real now behind the scenes in games
we'd had a limit for a very long time
and the limit is behind the visuals the
actual information being exchanged
between players or entities in a single
game world has been deeply bounded by
the fact that games mostly take place on
a single server or a single machine even
the world of warcraft is actually
thousands of smaller worlds when you
hear about concepts in fortnight you're
actually hearing about
thousands of small concerts and you know
individual as was said earlier today
campfires or couches there isn't really
this possibility to bring it all
together so let's take a moment to just
really understand what that means when
you look at the game you might see this
you might see beautiful visuals all of
these things happening in front of you
but behind the scenes at an online game
this is what it looks like to a computer
scientist all you see is just a little
bit of information being exchanged by a
tiny handful of meaningful entities or
objects now you might be thinking here
I've played in an infinite world well
it's more that you've played on a
treadmill and as you've been walking
through that world
we've been cleverly causing the parts of
it that you're not into vanish in the
parts of it in front of you to appear a
good trick but not the basis for the
revolution that I promised you in the
beginning of this talk but the reality
is for those of you that are passionate
gamers and might be excited by this and
for those of you that are afraid and may
not be that all of that is about to
change and it's going to change because
finally the technology is in place to go
well beyond the limits that we've
previously seen
now I've dedicated my career to this I
know there are many others working on
the problem at hardly take credit for it
myself but we're at the point now where
we can finally do this impossible hard
thing of weaving together thousands of
disparate machines into single
simulations that are convenient enough
and not be one offs but to be buildable
by anybody and to be at the point where
we can start to experience those things
that we can't yet fathom so let's just
take a moment to visualize that right I
mean I'm talking about not individual
little simulations but a massive
possibility of huge networks of
interaction massive global events that
can happen inside that things that even
in the real world become challenging to
to produce at that kind of scale and I
know some of you are gamers so I'm going
to show you some footage of some things
that I'm pretty sure I'm allowed to do
from some of our partners didn't we had
a back and forth on this and these are a
few things that not many people have
seen before and these are some new
experiences powered by this type of
technology so I'll just give a moment to
show you some of this stuff this is a
single game world with thousands of
simultaneous people participating in a
contract it also has its own ecosystem
its own sense of predator and prey every
single object you see here is simulated
in some way this is a game being built
by one of the biggest companies in the
world methines huge Chinese company and
they've made a
sistent creative simulation where groups
of players can co-create together across
multiple devices in a world doesn't
vanish when you're done it's a place to
tell stories and have adventure I mean
even the weather is simulated and that's
kind of Awesome and this is my personal
favorite and this is a group of people
pioneers in Berlin a group called trying
games and they're completely insane and
they love me for saying that and they
found a way to model basically an entire
planet so they're gonna have a
simulation with millions of non player
characters and players engaging they
actually grabbed Lawrence Lessig to help
understand the political ramifications
of the world that they're creating I
mean this is the sort of astounding set
of experiences well beyond what we might
have imagined that are now going to be
possible and that's just the first step
in this technology so if we step beyond
that what happens
well computer science tends to be all
exponential once we crack the really
hard problems and I'm pretty sure that
very soon we're going to be in a place
where we can make this type of
computational power look like nothing
and when that happens the opportunities
they it's worth taking a moment to try
to imagine what I'm talking about here
like I'm talking about hundreds of
thousands or millions of people being
able to Co inhabit the same space the
last time any of us as a species had the
opportunity to build something together
do something together with that many
people was in antiquity and the
circumstances were less than optimal
shall we say mostly conflicts or
building pyramids not necessarily the
best thing for us to be spending our
time doing but if you bring together
that many people the kind of shared
experience that can create I mean I
think it exercises a social muscle in us
that we've lost and forgotten but going
even beyond that I want to take a moment
to think about what it means for
relationships for identity like if we
can give each other worlds experiences
at scale or we can spend a meaningful
amount of our time we can change what it
means to be an individual we can go
beyond a single identity do a diverse
set of personal identities the gender
the race the personality traits you were
born with might be something you want to
experiment differently with you might be
someone that wants to be more than one
person I mean we all are inside multiple
people we really get the opportunity to
flex top it's also about empathy I mean
I have a grandmother who I have
literally nothing in common with I love
her to bits but every story she has
begins in 1940 and ends
sometime in 1950 and every story I have
is like fifty years later but if we
could Co inhabit go experience things
together that undiminished by physical
frailty or by lack of context create
opportunities together that changes
things that Bond's people in different
ways I'm struck by how social media has
amplified our many differences and
really made us more who we are in the
presence of other people I think games
could really start to create an
opportunity for us to empathize again to
have shared adversity shared opportunity
I mean statistically at this moment in
time there are people who are in on the
opposite sides of a conflict who've been
match made together into a game and
don't even know it I mean that's an
incredible opportunity to change the way
we look at things now finally for those
of you that perhaps are more cynical
about all of this right who maybe don't
think that virtual worlds and games are
your cup of tea there's a reality you
have to accept and that is that the
economic impact of what I'm talking
about will be profound right now
thousands of people have full-time jobs
in gaming soon it will be millions of
people wherever there's a mobile phone
there will be a job an opportunity for
something that is creative and rich and
gives you an income no matter what
country you're in no matter what skills
or opportunities you might think you
have probably the first dollar most kids
born today make might be in a game you
know that'll be the new paper route
that'll be the new opportunity for an
income at the earliest time in your life
so I kind of want to end with almost a
plea really more than more than thoughts
a sense of I think how we need to face
this new opportunity a little
differently to some that we have in the
past
I mean it's so hypocritical for yet
another technologists to stand up on
stage and say the future will be great
technology will fix it and the reality
is this is going to have downsides but
those downsides will only be amplified
if we approach once again with cynicism
and the reason the reason the
opportunities that this presents you
know the worst thing that we could
possibly do is let the same four or five
companies end up dominating yet another
adjacent space
because they're not just going to define
how and who makes money from this the
reality is we're now talking about
defining how we think what the rules are
around identity and collaboration the
rules of the world we live in this has
got to be something we all own we all
co-create so my final plea is really to
those engineers those scientists those
artists in the audience today maybe some
of you dreamed of working on space
travel the reality is there are worlds
you can build right here right now that
can transform people's lives there are
still huge technological frontiers that
need to be overcome here akin to those
we faced when building the early
Internet
all the technology behind virtual worlds
is different so my plea to you is this
let's engage let's all engage let's
actually try to make this something that
we shape in a positive way rather than
once again have be done to us thank you
[Applause]